[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta de verdad
tiene rossi un sistema capitalista han
pasado más de 30 años desde la
disolución de la unión soviética de
hecho aquí en visual político le hemos
dedicado un vídeo hace poco tiempo es
decir rusia ha abandonado el comunismo
pero de verdad podemos decir que rusia
tiene un sistema de mercado libre y
capitalista como lo puede tener eeuu o
europa es más hasta qué punto rusia ha
mejorado con respecto a cómo estaba en
la época soviética querida comunidad de
visual política sé que en los últimos
meses todo el mundo quiere oír hablar de
la política exterior de rusia sobre todo
en lo referente a ucrania pero hoy vamos
a adentrarnos en lo que ocurre dentro de
rusia
[Aplausos]
porque seamos claros rusia puede ser una
potencia militar pero en lo que a
bienestar de sus ciudadanos respecta a
este país está muy lejos de entrar en
eso que llamaríamos el primer mundo y
alguno me dirá hey fonseca pues yo he
estado en moscú y pareció una ciudad
europea cualquiera pues lo cierto es que
rusia es muy grande y fuera de las
grandes capitales podemos encontrar unas
regiones como la república de karelia
con un pib per cápita equivalente al de
libia o por ejemplo osetia del norte que
podría compararse incluso con un país
africano como yibutí
las cifras están ahí rusia es un gigante
en los recursos naturales tienen gas
natural y tienen petróleo pero sus
ciudadanos ven muy poco de esa riqueza
de hecho algunos se llegan a plantear si
no estaban mejor durante el comunismo
atentos a lo que yo voy a decir el
propio vladimir putin al respecto y en
noche de menos la unión soviética no
tiene corazón quien quiera que vuelva no
tiene cerebro vladimir putin y respecto
al capítulo de libertad y democracia
hablar cualquiera que se atreva a hacer
oposición a putin corre el riesgo de
acabar en la cárcel o incluso morir
envenenado y si no que se lo pregunten a
alexéi navalni oa tantos otros
activistas que no han dado tanto de qué
hablar en los medios de comunicación
pero todo eso ya lo sabéis especialmente
si sois miembros veteranos de esta
ilustre comunidad que es visual político
que seguramente no sepáis es la historia
de cómo rusia ha llegado hasta aquí una
historia que tiene dos protagonistas
boris yeltsin y vladimir putin y que
significa exactamente eso del
capitalismo de los siloviki si no os
preocupéis que al final del vídeo lo
entenderéis todo porque las preguntas
que nos hacemos son porque ha fracasado
la transición de rusia al capitalismo
que ha hecho vladimir putin para
actualmente gobernar rusia con mano de
hierro hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes de continuar
tenemos que hablar de como la pandemia
nos ha traído un nuevo tipo de política
económica
[Música]
y pocos hablan ya de austeridad de
equilibrio presupuestario etcétera
estamos con un nuevo paradigma económico
donde el estado ya está jugando un rol
más importante la economía no digo que
nos tenga que gustar pero las cosas son
como son estas son las reglas y con
estas tenemos que jugar ahora y por eso
las tenemos que entender bien pues bien
de eso va el último vídeo que ha sacado
si lo hubiera sabido el canal sobre
finanzas creado por mucho activos en el
que colabora visual político de verdad
que merece la pena que le echéis un
vistazo en unos pocos minutos os dejan
muy claritas las claves que necesitáis
entender para poder ahorrar en unos
tiempos tan complicados como los que nos
tocan ahora os dejo el enlace en la
descripción y ahora sí vamos a ver un
poco de historia
i
la nueva rusia
en septiembre de 1991 se celebró en
moscú uno de los conciertos más
multitudinarias de todos los tiempos el
famoso monsters of rock de teloneros la
banda local st y después un cartel que
hace algo así como mi sueño húmedo
atentos the black crowes pantera
metálica y azul vamos que me sueltan a
mí por ahí y me hacen feliz su música
había sido censurada durante años por el
régimen comunista y sin embargo ahora
estaban tocando allí en pleno aeródromo
tú sí no
[Aplausos]
la simbología del viejo régimen está hoy
expuesta en estos negocios souvenir
estas gorras militares hoy las puede
comprar usted apenas por cinco dólares
estaba claro que las cosas estaban
cambiando en rúsia y la figura clave era
este señor que veis en pantalla boris y
el zinc en las primeras elecciones
democráticas consiguió hacerse con la
presidencia de la república socialista
soviética de rusia su papel
enfrentándose al golpe de estado que
organizaron el partido comunista y la
caj eve en agosto de 1991 fue decisivo
para que este alzamiento fracasará su
imagen subido un tanque dirigiéndose al
público en defensa de la democracia
disparó su popularidad
y
toda su popularidad todo su capital
político lo iba a emplear en acelerar el
cambio de una economía controlada por el
estado a una economía de libre mercado
el problema es que la transición al
capitalismo trae muchos problemas sobre
todo en el corto plazo
mons no es capitalismo y pensado así los
soviéticos tenían precios controlados
prácticamente todos los bienes tenían un
precio estipulado por el estado precio
que en muchos casos era más bajo que lo
que sería el precio de mercado
[Música]
de repente rusia se abrió al comercio
mundial con precios libres para todos
los bienes que ocurrió pues que los
precios de los bienes se dispararon de
un día para otro sin embargo tanto la
mayoría de los sueldos como las
pensiones de los jubilados seguían con
las cifras de la época comunista
conclusión pobreza alcoholismo y hasta
enfermedades infecciosas en la memoria
de todos los rusos que han vivido esta
época están esas latas de cangrejo que
enviaban ongs de finlandia y otros
países vecinos pero esperad un momento
porque hay que ser justos este no fue el
único problema veréis casi todos los
países excomunistas también sufrieron
unos niveles de inflación nacho vidal ya
no durante los años 90 sin embargo
muchos de ellos consiguieron levantar
cabeza porque también aumentaron su
productividad este es el caso por
ejemplo de polonia o república checa sin
embargo la economía rusa se hundió el
pib del país cayó a la mitad en tan sólo
unos pocos años y todo esto se explica
en parte por la corrupción
y él sin quería privatizar todas esas
empresas estatales pero el proceso
estaba tan viciado que al final todas
esas grandes compañías terminaron en
manos de oligarcas y diréis por qué pues
por resumir por poder continuar con esta
historia podríamos decir que fue un
proceso muy parecido al de las
privatizaciones en ucrania si queréis
conocer esta historia con más detalle os
dejo un vídeo donde lo explicamos en la
descripción pero lo importante es que
los rusos cada vez eran más pobres y la
popularidad de helsinn cayó hasta tal
punto que en el año 1993 tan solo dos
años después de llegar al poder el
congreso le quiso poner una moción de
censura y que creéis que hizo el bueno
de helsinn pues atentos y el sinn envía
tropas para expulsar del parlamento a
sus rivales armados se desata una feroz
batalla en la capital la casa blanca de
moscú sede del parlamento ruso fue
bombardeada por los tanques enviados
porque el zinc se produjeron cientos de
muertos y así es como por iu y el zinc
se dio cuenta de que eso de la
democracia no es tan bonito como lo
pintan días más tarde y el sinn redactó
una nueva constitución rusa para evitar
que el parlamento le pudiera hacer
sombra dicho de otra forma una
constitución muchísimo más autoritaria
sin embargo en occidente nadie y grace
porque
[Música]
yo creo que no hay nada más revelador
que esta cita en su momento el por
entonces presidente de eeuu bill clinton
llegó a decir esto sobre su homólogo
ruso atentos nunca podemos olvidar que
el símbolo es mejor que la mayoría de
las alternativas sobrias palabras del
presidente bill clinton según el ex
subsecretario de estado estruch talbot y
no no es nuestro tipo cultural tú te vas
de fiesta con el zinc y volvía sobrio
porque se debía su vodka el tuyo y el de
todos tus amigos veréis la política
mundial nos ha dado a grandes
alcohólicos que pasaron a la historia
pero lo de helsinn se lleva la palma
atentos un boliche sin borracho fue
encontrado fuera de la casa blanca' en
ropa interior tratando de llamar un taxi
porque quería pizza dicho de otra forma
para occidente y el zinc era un borracho
a simpático que al menos no daba
problemas pero para los rusos y el zinc
era un borracho que no era capaz de
solucionarlos y ojo porque no sólo
hablamos de problemas económicos en 1994
rusia entró en guerra con los
separatistas chechenos en estos momentos
pensaréis que la situación no podía ir a
peor pero fue justo en esta situación
cuando pones y el sinn dijo eso de su el
vodka ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el colapso a la cima
en el año 1995 la situación económica de
rusia seguía siendo lamentable así que
el gobierno de helsinn tuvo la feliz
idea de iniciar un nuevo esquema para
una segunda ola de privatizaciones
hablamos del conocido como préstamos por
acciones la idea era que los oligarcas
rusos prestaban dinero al estado a
cambio de hacerse con la gestión de las
empresas estatales más valiosas las
gasísticas las petroleras etcétera si el
estado no devolvía los préstamos a
tiempo estos préstamos se convertían en
acciones y que creéis que ocurrió
exacto los oligarcas se hicieron con
empresas gigantes a precio de saldo por
ejemplo el campo de estos oligarcas
rusos borís berezovski se hizo con la
petrolera sibneft valorada atentos en
tres mil millones de dólares gracias a
un préstamo de 200 millones de dólares
al estado ruso pero este es sólo un
ejemplo para año 1996 y el sinn ya se
había encargado de crear una generación
de multimillonarios que le debían muchos
favores y creedme estos millonarios
sabían cómo devolverlos y diréis como
los devolvieron pues con apoyo electoral
[Música]
en 1996 rusia tenía elecciones pero la
mayoría de los medios estaban en manos
de estos oligarcas el principal opositor
de helsinn por aquel entonces era un tal
que nadie ziugánov que era el líder del
partido comunista un paréntesis este
señor sigue siendo el líder del partido
comunista hoy en día que ya han pasado
nada menos que 26 años de aquellas
elecciones vamos que eso de los amigos
vitalicios en rusia está en todas partes
fin del paréntesis el caso es que los
oligarcas apoyaron ayer sin sin
paliativos y él sin que estaba muy abajo
en las encuestas ganó las elecciones y
estaba muy contento como de contento
pues así de contento
[Música]
no me podéis negar que este hombre era
entrañable cuanto menos es que es
imposible que te caiga mal
eran buenos tiempos para yelsin y los
oligarcas pero malos tiempos para rusia
en 1998 se produjo la crisis financiera
rusa que ya os contamos con más detalle
en otro vídeo que os dejo en la
descripción pero por resumir la moneda
rusa perdió un 70% de su valor de la
noche a la mañana pero la caída del
rublo no se detuvo ahí en diciembre de
1998 se necesitaban el triple de rublos
y en agosto para obtener un dólar lo
bueno es que como bien sabéis crisis es
sinónimo de oportunidad una moneda débil
permite a las empresas de un país ganar
en competitividad al menos en el corto
plazo así que en 1998 fue un punto de
inflexión
la economía rusa revivió y las reformas
económicas de helsinn empezaron a dar
resultado 1999 fue el primer año de una
senda de crecimiento que se extendió
hasta que en 2008 estalló a nivel
mundial la gran recesión entre 1999 y
2008 rusia tuvo un crecimiento económico
promedio anual del 6 9% en esto tuvo
bastante que ver el precio del petróleo
el barril de brent pasó de costar 10
dólares a comienzos de 1999 a rebasar
los 50 en 2005 y alcanzar los 140
dólares en verano de 2008 el que más se
benefició de esta época de bonanza
tienen nombre y apellidos y aquí es
cuando por fin entra en escena el hombre
que estabais esperando vladimir putin en
agosto de 1999 putin se convirtió en
primer ministro y el 31 de diciembre en
presidente del país y el zinc acordó con
putin el blindaje de su inmunidad y
justo después de emitió arrancaba una
nueva era para rusia
[Música]
y los viking
el crecimiento económico disparo el
consumo en el país por fin los rusos
empezaban a notar diferencias después de
haber dejado atrás el estancamiento del
comunismo soviético y seamos honestos en
principio putin tomó buenas decisiones
eligió como principal asesor económico
andrei hilarión of un economista liberal
su gobierno simplificó y redujo los
impuestos utilizó con prudencia a los
multimillonarios ingresos que el estado
estaba obteniendo con el alza del precio
del crudo cada vez más importante para
la economía del país
putin culminó muchas de las reformas
concebidas en los años 90 incluida la
legislación para mejorar el sistema
judicial pero todos los esfuerzos por
reforzar la seguridad jurídica de putin
saltaron por los aires con el caso yukos
en 2003 rusia arrestó a mijaíl
jodorkovski que en aquel momento era el
hombre más rico del país gracias al
éxito de yukos que se había convertido
en la principal petrolera rusa un año
después yukos fue desmembrada y sus
activos asumidos por rosneft una empresa
petrolera perteneciente al estado
condenado por fraude fiscal
jodorkovski fue encarcelado en siberia
pasó una década en prisión hasta que fue
indultado por putin y desde entonces
vive exiliado en reinounido el caso
yukos fue el comienzo de una guerra de
putin contra los oligarcas pensando bien
atacar a los oligarcas era una medida
muy popular la gente sentía que aquellos
hombres de negocios se habían apropiado
de las riquezas del país el problema el
problema es que putin no emprendió esta
guerra para crear una economía realmente
capitalista donde hubiera competencia
entre empresas simplemente cambió a la
vieja casta de oligarcas por otra
los amigos de yeltsin pasamos a los
amigos de putin más conocidos como los
siloviki y diréis pero qué es eso de un
siloviki pues un sido vicky es un
político empresario que viene del
ejército o de alguna agencia de
seguridad como el que ven recordad que
putin empezó su carrera como espía de la
calle por ejemplo como ya hemos dicho
una de las empresas más importantes de
rusia es la petrolera rosneft pues bien
desde el año 2012 su ceo es un tal igor
se gen ex espía de la caja y mano
derecha de putin durante sus primeros
años en el kremlin soy consciente de que
su nombre no sonará de nada pero seguro
que su apodo os dice bastante de la
personalidad de este individuo
así es como el darth vader de rusia
emergió de las sombras para convertirse
en el zar del petróleo de putin como
estáis viendo en rusia impera un
capitalismo de amiguetes es la era de
los siloviki y podríamos decir que
tienen algo así como una democracia
digital porque el dedo de putin marca el
destino de los nuevos ricos de rusia
cualquier aventurero que intente hacer
fortuna sabe que puede perder el favor
del estado si se sale ligeramente de la
línea oficial o si se vuelve demasiado
y sus activos comienzan a parecer
demasiado atractivos a alguno de estos
siglo big is
[Música]
y ahí está la historia por ejemplo de
igor buscar el propietario de una gran
empresa de cemento en el extremo oriente
ruso pues bien buscar él se unió al
partido de putin y el año 2008 fue
elegido alcalde de vladivostok en el año
2016 se le ocurrió desafiar en las
primarias del partido a vladimir micro
sets y el gobernador regional pues bien
microsoft llamó a putin y como decimos
en visual político dicho y hecho el
alcalde de la vostok acusado de
corrupción y abuso de poder pero sin
duda alguna la historia que mejor
explica cómo funciona la economía rusa
hoy en día es la de vladimir
yevtushenkov este buen señor es o era el
propietario de sistema una empresa de
inversiones en 2009 sistema compró por
2.500 millones de dólares una
participación de control en bases net
asnef era una petrolera de tamaño medio
pero la compañía resulta y empezó a
crecer rápidamente y se convirtió en uno
de los mayores productores de derivados
de petróleo gracias a sus refinerías y
que creéis que pasa pues que en 2014 el
bueno de vladimir fue arrestado
el verdadero motivo de su arresto fue
que se negaba a vender esta petrolera al
gigante rosneft cuyo ceo es el amigo de
putin cuando diréis que le sacaron de la
cárcel pues cuando acertó a la venta a
cambio de cinco mil doscientos millones
de dólares más una indemnización de dos
mil millones de dólares años más tarde
el bueno de vladimir ya ha aprendido la
lección el estado tiene el derecho de
tomar cualquier decisión les guste o no
a las empresas puede haber algunas
consecuencias desagradables para alguien
las hubo para nosotros pero así es la
vida los negocios deben trabajar por el
bien del estado tan pronto como se
pierde de vista eso siempre sucede algo
desagradable vladimir yevtushenkov rusia
enfocado a la modernización de su
economía como una cuestión de tecnología
y no como una estrategia de apertura a
los mercados internacionales y de
seguridad jurídica que se haya
convertido en un régimen autoritario
tampoco ayuda a ver la política exterior
de rusia tampoco está ayudando mucho con
la economía así que la pregunta es
creéis que putin será sucedido algún día
por alguno de estos siloviki o pensáis
que pasará igual que con la unión
soviética y llegará un momento en el que
este sistema colapse dejadme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y por
supuesto no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos este canal y
darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]